what's going on reject nation Greg here
John here know what next month is what
is it October Greg is that what you're
gonna sit over is when it's evil but you
know it comes out the month after
October Oh November November where
apparently there are still November
criminals instead we're gonna watch it
there right stars Angela Lord and Chloe
is gonna be I don't know a steam in
Prague that's how I do improv on stage
your girls in this I was gonna do a joke
when I decided not see that's suppose
every that's me every improv show your
girls in this movie are grateful rats
yeah
chloë grace moretz mature con sexuality
drugs thematic troubles it's the opening
of baby driver
[Music]
he's gonna die set it up like he's gonna
die good man
[Music]
our emotions are raw everybody in this
room is hurting Kevin brought us was not
in a game we appreciate your time will
you please send the next person
you can't expect me just to sit around
and not do anything about
the police have already made up their
minds they're gonna write this whole
thing off as a game killer someone needs
to do something
white boy was likely people help me
[Music]
to stop this nonsense this is a murder
investigation you don't know what could
happen
he's mixed up with so many people
they're dangerous
[Music]
call for backup
why can't find this
you know if you tried talking about
doing crazy don't bother
[Music]
interesting John yes I need to be more
honest with myself these days okay I
think this script and the acting will be
better than the directing I think plot
wise interesting there's some compelling
elements to it yeah no high school Stora
Enso
these tubes are still in high school
high school white kids it applies to
white kids who have a black friend black
friend gets killed there trying to
justify it as a game killing because the
kids black yeah I think there's a
compelling element to that they're
trying to pinpoint it the friend is
trying to be like no I need to find
evidence and prove that he was involved
in gangs just cuz he's black doesn't
mean that I know my buddy and this is
how you know he's a barista or something
the cashier at a coffee shop come on I
like that compelling plot point but in
terms of like tone in the way it's
looking captured it kind of feels like
other a Chloe grace Moretz movies that
are trying to be more edgy you know and
part of me wonders is this has maybe
been sitting around for a while and is
getting a release now that baby driver
has been sister 6 I kind of get that
impression I get the vibes of those
closures from as like if I stay meets
the cancer movie that he was in what was
that 100 star and our stars but with
this edgy twist to it but it has he has
the tone of those kind of team driven
audience films I know what people say
when you when you don't really love a
trailer is just just wait for the movie
and I and I I kind of fit what's command
December was come I was now it's called
November criminal Christmas it's pg-13
it's a pg-13 film but I feel like could
probably be more compelling if they were
willing to make it more of an r-rated
piece of material yeah it just seems
like they're probably gonna hold back a
little bit and I feel like there's gonna
be more compelling points on paper that
are probably not gonna be explored here
or to its fullest degree yeah and I sort
of wonder if yeah it'll kind of
the punches and tailor the drama you
younger people which isn't necessarily a
bad thing you know I feel like there is
a certain amount of heavy impact that it
might miss in doing that thirteen to
seventeen year olds need movies - yeah
sure good films though this film does
not look like it's gonna be a terrible
film yes you know tell me okay that's
the most like when it looks like this
could be really good compelling crime
drama if it's just gonna be okay more of
a teen drama like type of movie more
than anything else yeah I feel ago fall
down some cliche and predictable paths
cuz even and even in the opening scene
it was because of the way it was
directed you have a good day man you're
my buddy let's cut to a shot good man
good man cooked a shot right I'm like oh
he's gonna die yeah damn he dies right
away yeah so I feel like it's probably
gonna come down more to the directing of
this film not being the greatest thing
in the world and sometimes I keep my
mouth shut on trailers but I mean I'm
gonna be a little more US if I'm wrong
I'm wrong I'm gladly a minute I am I'm
good at the middle one I'm wrong I've
dated several people to have skills in
that ya know and I kind of agree with
you at the end of the day just watching
this one trailer anyhow is sitting there
going you know I like a lot of people
involved in this but it just didn't grip
me to the point where I was like gotta
see this yeah it's gonna be great you
know it did leave me sort of wondering
if this could be you know Hallmark II
and sort of cheesy or if it is you know
and I could really see it going either
way and also you know just given the
circumstances and this is the first I've
heard about this movie Chloe Moretz is
barely in this trailer so I'm wondering
like what is her deal you know like
what's her characters supposed to be or
is she just kind of a science Oh like I
get it like it seems like Ansel Elgort
is this dude who has like a good life in
high school he's got a good girlfriend
he's friends with everybody
Frank gets killed and now his life is
deteriorating he's losing sight of it
and now is like his relationships
falling apart as well as supportive
girlfriend doesn't want to be supportive
of in this subject anymore I get this
the the purpose she's supposed to sir
as a character here but she feels more
like plot device for Ansel Elgort than
it does that sound like we're reviewing
the whole I feel like I'm gonna be right
I don't know well what do you guys think
do you hate me for saying that do you
just love do you guys think these two
actors can just do no wrong you mad that
we just talking about the trailer or not
the movie itself was his way to the
actual book and it gets good reviews and
people like it if I like yeah well I
don't go in with that kind of mind and
heart yeah yeah I mean I hope it works
out I'm a little afraid to yeah it's
gonna be like beautiful white kids help
out the black you you know anytime you
walk in it it's like it's not that that
can't work but I'm a little bit like
right and I kind of agree it seems like
I might have been sitting on the shelf
for a while because they're playing high
schoolers still well that's what I guess
I guess that's what I meant by the chloe
moretz thing is like the focus of this
trailer is clearly on Ansel Elgort
he gets all of the compelling moments of
this trailer we get a glimpse into his
performance whereas her like she pops up
but like almost none of those scenes
actually capitalize on like what she's
bringing to already yeah that she's
there's all I know about her and this is
that she's there and I can guess a lot
of things like her that's where we
disagree though because I it's been a
while since I've lost her Chloe
[Applause]
nobody knows her my time machine is not
accessible for all the mankind describe
to the real rejects do it click that
notification bell - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram and hey if you
still like us patreon.com slash the real
rejects become a patronage act Hey